ciao mariners e benvenuti questo
nuovissimo video
oggi parleremo di capodanno
piccola premessa sul capodanno allora da
ragazzini chiaramente è il capodanno
tipo è l'evento della vita lo aspettiamo
con ansia e pensiamo che succeda chissà
cosa poi alla fine è un giorno come un
altro e quindi pace e amore e fantasia
che il capodanno è un giorno come tutti
gli altri dovete si chiama festeggiare
sempre nei limiti senza pensare che
succeda chissà cosa perché semplicemente
l'ultimo giorno dell'anno partire subito
consolando chi mi sta guardando in
questo momento e odia il capodanno
oppure abbassato ovviamente dei
capodanni cioè negli ultimi anni dei
capodanni tremendi non sapete cosa vi
aspetta
sì perché davanti a voi in questo
momento avrete la regina dei capodanni
flop ma cose di colli imperatrice
dell'universo dei capodanni flop
il primo capodanno flock vi voglio
raccontare è sicuramente etico passerò
una storia a sé se mi chiedono un
capodanno da raccontare il racconto
sempre quello perché mi fa molto ridere
adesso quell'anno lì un po meno
io ero una ragazzina avevo tipo
14 queen o 15 anni e avevo questo
fidanzatino di cui chiaramente ero
innamorata persa ed era più grande di me
allora vi descrivo nati una tipologia di
ragazzino proprio quello delle serie tv
biondino fisichino carino e insomma era
il bonazzo della compagna di justin
bieber della compagnia
io ero innamorata persa un giorno
miracolosamente succede che questo
ragazzino mi chiede di fidanzarci e
quindi le campane suonarono a festa gli
usignoli mularoni nel buio della mia
vita e io mi fidanzai con questo ragazzo
e voi vi confermerete un po di tv
d'angelo un ragazzo cioè proprio gli
occhi a cuoricino tutto bellissimo
cosa succede dopo ti poni un mese mirage
e io cado nelle tenebre dell'abbandono e
voi direte ci siamo passate tutte
sì ma non avete ancora scoperto il clou
del discorso e cioè il capodanno
qualche mese dopo ma neanche troppi mesi
cioè sono stati due mesi dopo era
capodanno e io con la mia compagnia
avevo deciso di passare il capodanno
nella casa di campagna della mia
migliore amica
immaginate quando la mia migliore amica
mi guarda mi dice vedi ke c'è anke hicks
cioè il mio ex viene a fare capodanno
cosa era arrivato il momento di
riconquistarlo perché lui a capodanno mi
avrebbe visto più bella che mai e ci
sarebbe di nuovo innamorato di me mi
avrebbe chiesto scusa per quei due mesi
di completo abbandono e io chiaramente
avrei ceduto
tornando con lui arriva il famoso
capodanno immaginatevi una marina
adolescente combinata stile ariana
grande questo trucco ha fatto 30 mila
volte peggio però il mood ma mi sentivo
veramente veramente [ __ ] e mi
confermerete voi la casa che quando c'è
il ragazzino di cui si è innamorata
ci pensi sette mesi prima cosa metterti
oa come combinati insomma era stato un
lungo percorso verso quella sera di
capodanno ed io ero pronta a vederlo
pronta a riconquistarlo inizia il
capodanno e il tuo cuore
lui ancora non c'è di lui non c'è
traccia io li cado in depressione perché
dico non verrà più
e proprio quando ormai avevo
completamente perso le speranze
lo vedo lo vedo in tutto il suo
splendore colpito da un raggio da un
fascio di luce che insomma lo illumina e
mi indica la strada verso il paradiso
lui mi guarda mi sorride io mi sciolgo
ed è proprio lì che dietro di lui vedo
suo nuovo fidanzato
erano mesi che aspettavo quel giorno per
riconquistarlo
mi ero programmata e preparata tutto il
discorso ma non c'era niente da fare
perché lui era lì con una sorta di
barbie californiana bionda abbronzata
manco invece alle mauritius è perfetta
ecco io in quel momento mi son sentita
una cacchina devo andare via ma dove
andavo grandi in mezzo alla campagna
ma ahimè non è finito qui perché nel
pacchetto comprensivo del camposanto
nella casa di campagna
c'era anche il pigiama party perché
avremo dormito tutti lì ecco non so se
avete presente le case di campagna
sommando queste camere goss eccetera
eccetera e la camera dei genitori era
stata chiusa quindi c'era sotto una
camera per tutti quindi immaginate che
insomma lui si è fermato a dormire con
lei e io non potevo scappare perché non
c'erano proprio non c'era modo di
scappare una ragazzina non potevo che
variano da dire mamma benini a prendere
perché c'è lui eccetera eccetera insomma
mi ama non sapeva neanche in questa
storia quindi
il momento più flop del capodanno non è
stato quando io l'ho visto con lei ma è
stato quando io ho dovuto dormire nella
stessa stanza in cui dormivano loro due
e sentire per tutta la notte e loro
limoni e duri e vi assicuro che adesso
rito ma c'era molto da piangere
immaginatevi una ragazzina col cuore
infranto nel bel mezzo del capodanno
assolutamente da dimenticare
questo era insomma il top del flop ma
c'è sempre un altro flop che vorrei
raccontarvi a proposito di capodanno che
hanno dopo il capodanno che vi ho appena
raccontato non avevo alcun programma
perché non aveva uno straccio di
fidanzato le mie amiche avevano già
tutti organizzato eccetera eccetera
grazie a dio c'era la mia migliore amica
che come sempre mi salva nei momenti
critici è la mia migliore amica era
stata invitata a un capodanno in
montagna appunto a casa dei suoi amici
che io non conoscevo quindi immaginatevi
la situa la mia migliore amica
il suo fidanzato al 33 mie amiche i loro
fidanzati in una casa in montagna piena
di gente che non conoscevo
però voi mi confermerete che a volte le
situazioni che meno ti aspetti possono
essere molto divertenti possono essere
delle piacevoli sorprese
ecco questa non è stata perché io sono
arrivata in quella casa appunto in alta
montagna quindi non è che dice c'è
un'alternativa me ne va da un'altra
parte è rowling la baita e c'era c'era
un gruppo di ragazzi appunto della
nostra età una trentina di persone che
vi assicuro avevano la faccia della
morte musica non c'era almeno cosa è
arrivata non c'era poi dopo l'hanno
messa perché chiaramente ho insistito
cibo c'era ma nessuno lo mangiava quindi
un gruppo di ragazzi tutti a dieta
l'allegria e la voglia di festeggiare
non c'era assolutamente proprio non era
pervenuta quindi mi sono sentite in
qualche modo di animare un po la situa
voi immaginate le immaginatemi lì dentro
insomma da dove si inizia quando la
situazione così smorta inizi con la
musica cosa mettevo di musica è che
potevo mettere l'ala usa queste musiche
qui insomma che dopo un po suo nome sono
la bella per scaldare la pista no
raffaella carrà dai ragazzi insomma mi
hanno guardato tutti male cioè io ho
portato mio spirito festivo da serata
pop trash anni 80 90 70 revival nessuno
mi ha capita quindi io l'ho detto adesso
esploderà la festa sarò la regina della
serata perché tutti mi ringrazieranno di
questo questo sprint di questo sprizzo
di allegria
mi hanno guardato malissimo
cioè proprio mi sono vergognata come mai
in vita mia ma non è che ho spento tutte
me ne sono andata perché come detto
prima non c'era modo di andarsene niente
io me ne sono fregato ragazzi perché il
bello della vita essere se stessi e
quindi ho ballato tutta la sera da
raffaella carrà a sabrina salerno alle
spice a britney spears e non me ne
fregava niente di nessuno fino a quando
è arrivato il momento del brindisi
perché se fino a quel momento ci diciamo
mi ero fatto andare bene la situazione
oli che cercavo un attimo di tirare e
mezzo le persone senza riuscirci
quando è arrivato il momento del
brindisi diciamo che tutta la mia voglia
di festeggiare nonostante la gente non
avesse voglia di festeggiare è andata un
attimo a quel paese perché 32 auguri
tipico source e fino a quel momento
pensavo che soltanto le mie amiche
fossero tutte a coppie quindi ho pensato
sono l'unica sfigata da vere amiche
tutte fidanzate mi sono resa conto che
tutte casa era accoppiata ai ragazzi ero
l'unica single tutti si sbaciucchiavano
e io
immaginatevi così cappellino cappellino
in testa di quelli capodanno trombetta
di una storia triste e raffaella carrà
di sottofondo io penso che con questa
immagine possiamo concludere capodanni
più from di marina